[Música]
y pues llegamos a nuestro momento de
saludar a nuestro segundo invitado del
día ls manel loureiro escritor abogado y
también presentador de televisión de
televisión autor de varios libros entre
ellos su más reciente la ladrona de
huesos manel gracias por estar con
nosotros en france 24 en español aquí en
la ciudad de bogotá le quiero preguntar
antes de todo que si ha dormido además
cómo le ha ido con el jetlag pues mira
precisamente mientras las niñas de aquí
estaba asombrado de los horarios estos
madrugones que cierto colombia es un
país que madruga madrugador muy
madrugador y además en mi caso bueno
pues tengo la mezcla de varios jetlag
cel yecla que traigo desde europa a
américa y el del luck de ir cambiando de
distintos países con lo cual qué quieres
que te diga a dormir duermo cuando puedo
cuando me dejan y lo que puedo las
novelas que trasnochan el proceso de
escritura digamos de trasnoche si yo soy
pájaro nocturno es que a mí me gusta ese
momento de tranquilidad en el que ya no
está nadie porque está todo el mundo en
esa fase rem que decía esta compañera
tuya que lo explicaba esta manera tan
admirable y yo puedo escribir
tranquilamente sin que nadie me moleste
qué es lo que más te gusta digamos del
proceso creativo cuando haces
fuiste presentado no sé si todavía era
seguidor de televisión
abogado como dijiste pues quiero ahora
incursionar en el mundo de la escritura
además a ser un thriller digamos de una
novela de ficción pues la verdad es que
yo empecé a escribir por accidente me
encantaría poder contar una historia de
que tenía una vocación desde muy desde
muy pequeño que fue una especie de
revelación pero no trabajaba como
abogado y la literatura jurídica me
tenía un poco saturado así que
necesitaba escribir algo que no fuese
esa literatura jurídica empecé a
escribir una historia en un blog lo más
alejado posible de ese mundo del derecho
y para mi sorpresa aquello se transformó
en un fenómeno viral y de repente en
cuestión de seis meses tenía un millón y
medio de lectores en todo el mundo a que
el blog se transformó en mi primera
novela esa primera novela se transformó
en un best seller se empezó a publicar
en un montón de países a traducirse un
montón de idiomas y entre otras cosas se
ha ido rebotando hasta llegar aquí estar
hoy aquí contigo con france24 contándote
esta historia en vez de seguir siendo un
abogado en españa hablar de la ladrona
de huesos que podemos encontrar en esta
novela digamos que tú escribiste como
que cuál es el punto que pudiera
enganchar a un lector a una persona que
tenga este nuevo dell en la mano la
ladrona de huesos es un thriller es una
historia que arranca una fría noche de
mayo cuando una pareja está cenando un
restaurante en un determinado momento
ella se levanta de la mesa y cuando
vuelve carlos su prometido ha
desaparecido pero no sólo es que haya
desaparecido es que no hay el más mínimo
rastro de los camareros incluso aseguran
que laura la protagonista ha estado
cenando sola todo el rato y cuando
empieza a pensar que se puede estar
volviendo loca de repente de algo una
diminuta pista que le hace sospechar que
lo han hecho desaparecer y esa sospecha
se transforma en una certeza cuando unos
minutos más tarde recibe una llamada
telefónica en la que una voz de hombre
le dice que sí lo quiere volver a ver
con vida tan solo tiene que hacer una
cosa el problema es que es imposible lo
que le piden que haga es que entre en la
catedral de santiago de compostela uno
de los templos más venerados y vigilados
de la cristiandad
las reliquias del apóstol santiago los
restos del apóstol santiago que se
encuentran en una cripta debajo del
altar mayor y los saque y para eso solo
tiene siete días digamos manel también
le quiero preguntar si esta novela tiene
por supuesto este famoso camino a
santiago de compostela si se desarrolla
también una parte en ese camino hasta
llegar a la catedral para poder hacer el
cometido que le pidieron esto digamos
secuestrados efectivamente el camino el
camino de santiago forma parte de la
historia el camino es una ruta que
arranca en prácticamente en el norte de
alemania y acaba desembocando en
santiago esa pequeña ciudad en el
noroeste de españa es uno de los ejes
vertebradores de europa es una ruta que
se lleva haciendo desde hace más de mil
años y que a día de hoy sigue atrayendo
a cientos de miles de viajeros
peregrinos algunos otros simplemente
curiosos que quieren vivir la
experiencia en todo caso es el entorno
perfecto para contar una historia como
ésta que tiene ingredientes de un robo
imposible espionaje y muchas muchas
incógnitas hay algo digamos de realidad
dentro de esta ficción
hay 100 una cierta dosis de realidad al
fin y al cabo no olvides que hace unos
años en la propia catedral de santiago
robaron el códice calixtino un libro es
que se considera que es la primera guía
de viajes de la historia el códice era
una guía para hacer ese camino y saber
dónde había que parar donde no se debía
parar qué sitios eran de fiar y qué
sitios eran peligrosos alguien robó ese
códice apareció unas semanas después
porque la policía ha actuado de manera
muy rápida pero toda esa suma de
experiencias de repente me llevaron a
plantearme una duda los grandes templos
de la cristiandad repartidos por todo el
mundo acumulan obras de arte de valor
incalculable y no siempre tienen las
medidas de seguridad que podemos esperar
en un museo o en una
una situación mucho más protegida me
parecía que era el punto de partida
perfecto para empezar a contar esta
historia y plantearnos eso qué pasaría
si alguien decidiese robar una de las
reliquias más sagradas de la cristiandad
manuel yo siempre me he preguntado
digamos como hace un escritor para poder
aterrizar todas esas ideas locas que se
le vienen a la cabeza es decir a uno
pues yo me considero una persona también
creativa y a veces como ideas y esto se
verá a lo mejor escribir una historia
sobre esto algo sobre otra cosa para el
final uno no termina como de concretarlo
realmente y plasmarlo entonces digamos
en el proceso creativo de un escritor en
este caso como como decir bueno me
siento y digamos mi imaginación ya la
aterrizó en algo material yo siento que
a lo mejor estás como que la etapa más
difícil que por supuesto cuando ya la
tienes ya no pasa nada ya sabes el
proceso pero como sé cómo fue ese
proceso inicial desde atrás y decir ya
basta de soñar vamos a materializar esta
idea y quizás lo más difícil es ser
capaz de separar lo que es una idea de
lo que es una historia no es lo mismo
una idea que una historia a mí si me
diesen un euro o un dólar por cada vez
que alguien me ha dicho tengo una idea
estupenda para un libro ya no tendría
que escribir no todas las ideas son
historias a una idea le tienes que hacer
preguntas te las tiene que responder y
esas preguntas tienen que generar más
preguntas que a su vez monten un
escenario completo cuando de repente una
idea se transforma en historia y cuando
esa historia empieza a obsesionarte y
cuando esa historia empieza a ser una
algo que ocupa mucho espacio en tu mente
has descubierto que eso es lo que tienes
que contar y eso se va a transformar en
un libro manel rápidamente en este libro
la ladrona de huesos o sea también
quería preguntarle por ese proceso
creativo en qué sentido ustedes tienen
ayuda a la hora de escribir o después
como algún tipo de editor alguien que
revise la novela pero digamos eso es más
técnico o se involucran de alguna manera
en el proceso creativo o sea cómo es eso
a la hora de plasmar esto en una
editorial digamos como planeta la labor
de editorial es muy importante los
editores son gente que a lo mejor no son
lo suficientemente creativos como para
escribir un libro pero tienen un talento
desbordante para diferenciar lo que
funciona de lo que no funciona en un
libro y siempre opinan siempre siempre
tratan de pulir esa es como si tú como
escritor sacas es un diamante en bruto
del fondo de un río y ellos fuesen como
esos
talleres donde pueden pulir esa pieza
con tu colaboración es decir quien al
final que tiene que realizar el pulido
eres tú pero quienes están sobre el
hombro aconsejando te solo
es conveniente hacerles caso y al mismo
tiempo es una buena ducha de humildad
para alguien ser un escritor que tienes
que ir montado en una considerable dosis
de ego porque te expones un montón y
está muy bien que alguien llegue y te
diga vale amigo está muy bien lo que has
hecho pero ahora lo vamos a corregir y
éste se sienta realmente bien